[Music]
in Papua New Guinea children are playing
like they do anywhere in the world but
these kids are at high risk of a
tropical skin disease that causes big
ulcers jaws is caused by a bacterium
that infects through wounds and
scratches usually on the legs it doesn't
kill but if left untreated it can
destroy bone tissue and cause permanent
pain and disfigurement in May 2018
Martin answering traveled to Papua New
Guinea I went to meet a Spanish doctor
and scientist named Oriole media he
spends most of his time on a tiny very
remote island named Li here and I wanted
to learn more about his efforts to not
just treat yours but to wipe it from the
face of the world well here is very poor
most people don't have running water or
electricity medical care is rudimentary
when media arrives in Li here in 2010 he
was really surprised to see lots of
cases of yours he had never even heard
of the disease even though he was
trained in tropical medicine until the
1950s yas was a huge global problem
there were as many as 50 million cases
Yas bacteria thrive in hot humid poor
and rural regions in 1954 the World
Health Organization launched an
ambitious campaign to eliminate the
disease using penicillin more than 50
million people received injections cases
dropped by 95 percent but the job was
never finished so by the 1990s Yas was
almost completely forgotten but the
bacterium wasn't gone and eventually it
bounced back what made eradication
difficult was that infected people who
no longer had symptoms often received no
treatment if they became sick again they
could infect others the only way to
prevent that would be to treat everyone
with or without symptoms but penicillin
injections are not ideal if done done
safely they can transmit blood-borne
pathogens they're also painful and
cumbersome six years ago meetcha found a
salut
'only here he did a clinical study and
and showed that a single dose of a
well-known antibiotic named AC firm
icing here's your's
just as well as a penicillin injection
azithromycin is cheap safe and easy to
administer Beach's research has changed
the way patients are treated it's also
revived the dream of Yas eradication the
World Health Organization said this is
great now we can eradicate yours after
all because with this drug it's fine to
treat entire populations on a
neighboring island meetcha is working
with the Papua New Guinea government to
test this strategy seeing the
researchers at work on this island made
me really appreciate just how daunting
studying like this is to try to reach
sixty thousand people in hundreds of
remote villages very poor area and
they're doing not just one but three
rounds six months apart the hope of
course is that this will make yours
disappear and if it works the same
strategy might be used to eradicate
yours globally what obstacles remained
nobody knows how widespread yas is today
only 14 countries report cases but
others may still have Yas as well an
eradication could cost a billion dollars
or more and no one has offered to foot
the bill some scientists even wonder
whether we can ever fully eradicate Yas
because the bacterium has also been
found in some primate species and other
races the question could it jump back to
humans from those animal reservoirs but
one thing is clear meetcha has put a
forgotten disease back on the agenda
more people are getting treatment
research on Yas is flourishing again
but struck me talking to people about
yours is that the optimism of the 1950's
seems to be back and maybe it's possible
for them to finish this job after all
[Music]
you
[Music]
you